hi welcome to games of the week this
week we have a fun stuff going on we
have such as still happening still about
to wrap up but today we had a pretty big
development and feed a woman World Chess
Championship the match between Alexandra
Cortina and Joe in June and so basically
this was game 12 and Julie engine only
needed a draw to win the whole match
because she was a point up but going
into the match and gory Alena needed to
win the game to force playoffs now let's
see how it happened so this is a very I
want to call it unusual line I'm pretty
sure it's called something like very
soft and I really haven't seen it happen
in high-level chess
very much at least recently but it's
always a good good move to try and trick
your opponent or like lure them into
unknown territories so I feel like it's
actually a pretty nice idea to do in a
situation at you it's a must win so
that's what happened and I'm pretty sure
it was preparation for Alexandra and she
followed up with the move Knight b5 so
95 is pretty simple I'm going for this
fork over here and the best way for
black to respond to it is with something
like 96 so like 5 4 moves in you can
already see that the position is
not something you were very used to to
think about it simply whitening is to
start developing more pieces you need to
bring out the night bring out the bishop
we take a better grip on the center so
the way to do that is to think about III
the idea after III is that white simply
wants to bring out the night
bring out the bishop the bishop is also
defending this B five nights so in the
game jus engine played Bishop before
check from what I know Bishop e7 could
also be the way to go and this was a
game between Robert Richard Roberts and
nh3 last weekend z-class Tata still
probably which is in weekend Z I don't
have the best pronunciation but thank
you
I've been there I still can't pronounce
it anyways so Bishop before is what
happened in this game and jus engine
took about eight minutes ish to think
about this move which leads me to
believe that the both players were
naturally in their opening repertoire
also if I'm not mistaken for just the
second move Knight f6 Jew engine took
about 20 minutes to make the decision
I I can understand how something like
that like the last round of all
championship could be so stressful that
you don't want to make any mistakes and
you want to do everything so perfect so
just to mention that yeah sometimes it's
super chess players also take about 20
minutes to think about their move to so
we left off somewhere around here and c3
is the only logical move I mean nice c3
is not really something you want to do
unless you absolutely have to
so c3 Bishop to e7
and now another move that was quite
strange in my eyes was a four I mean
this this is kind of I don't have to
exact words for it it's just really
interesting to see something like that
in such a high level chess but at the
same time there's nothing wrong with it
like white is gaining space but we're so
used to seeing developing and castling
and trying to do everything by the book
so black took the time to make Castille
something like c6 I think is interesting
I'm not sure if it's better than castle
or necessarily or not but after Knight
has to come to a tree and after that to
my castle you see the c6 kind of gives
White's
a clearer idea of what to attack whereas
just in castle white still doesn't have
that clear targets so maybe that's why
c6 wasn't played in the game they
followed up with Bishop d3 Bishop d3 is
nice Bishop is in a good position
good diagonal
keeping an eye on the kinks out and
having some hand in queenside so here
after castle Bishop d3 black played c6
finally tonight to a tree and here black
continued with c5 I I'm not sure exactly
why I can understand that for example if
c4 happens it's much stronger for black
to try and close up here a little bit
but whoops at the same time I think it's
a little hard to make decisions what do
you want to do with this bishop I mean I
guess my question is well couldn't you
just play C 5 now if you wanted to play
C 5 but I guess c6 is the better choice
and then when you move the knight c5 but
can't I just go back with the night
this was a game in 2017 between that
bortnik was white playing a lower rated
player if I'm not reading it right
finger off well anyways yeah this is
another way that they went about it 95
94 and then they developed simply and in
that game white one
it was board bortnik versus finger off
and 2017
anyways so however in the game they
played Knight f3 which is actually a
novelty but well this game I'm pretty
sure everything in the opening was
already super interesting alright so
after something like that of three the
idea is pretty clear white wants to
simply make sure it's castle and start
doing stuff in the queenside
so another question is how can black
respond to that because blacks pieces
are Pitman's place like this Knights
would have been way more useful summer
like c6 looking at Center while this
Bishop would be kind of better either
out here or already seen Bianchi to
position so the way black went about it
is with 94 I think 94 is actually pretty
interesting idea because black simply
wants to create more chances for
himself/herself sorry
with like something maybe for f5 trying
to do something in the center and Kings
side because White's king is going to be
most likely in the Queen side just based
off of pawn structures after Knight e4
white played each three black responded
with f5 and now white wins back 95
I would assume that 95 is simply because
night on a tree wasn't serving a purpose
and something like 95 keeps the pressure
on c7 square so this light can't move
and that's pretty much should be good
enough reason to play night b5 so after
95 black finally did this c4 that I
mentioned a few moves earlier and now
it's a critical time to think a little
bit about where you want to place your
Bishop do you want to keep your Bishop
somewhere like c2e2 maybe or if you
think this bishop job is done let's kick
it off out of the board so what do you
think
okay I like that idea and they actually
did that in the game too they just took
on e5 and knights came to e5 yeah the
thing is if I feel like if you were to
keep the Bishop on the board it would
simply make things more complicated
because some not entirely sure if it's
the best idea but you would have to be
cautious of something like g5 or simply
something like maybe Bishop d7 and then
Bishop would come to the better
diagonals whereas your Bishop won't
stick to essentially doing anything so I
think that's why Bishop efore was the
best move F takes e4 Knight e5 now
now we then light on e5 this Bishop is
kind of closed off so probably it's time
to relocate this nice right but where do
you want to go c7 p8 those laces haven't
even work
yeah I think that's that's a good idea
to try and play nice pH because 97 white
could simply take the Nile Queen takes
I'm 96 attractive rook and that's like
the Queen at the same time so yeah nice
beat it's a good move now how do you
think white should follow up should we
try to do something German drastic over
here or let's just do simple castle
yeah I agree because there is not much
dramatic stuff to do I mean
theoretically a lot of stuff could be
happening with f3 but I feel like you
need to be prepared for it better with
Castle first and then trying to prepare
f3 or like b3 and going after those
pawns in C 4 and C 4 so Castle black
would simply play a6 which makes sense
right this Knight is pretty strong here
and you you actually move your knife to
be able to kick this night out so let's
go for it
93 is the only move 97 is very logical
you're attacking why it's East 5 night
and you might want to take it or you
might even want to keep the knight on
the board dependent whoops depending on
how the position would go yes
Oh
mmm queen g4 it was a nice idea but it's
not really realistic because something
like simply take on e5 or simply Knight
f6 and you have to move your queen again
yeah and like where would you go 935
I'll an F for night falls it's not the
right time to start any sort of attack
when these puns are so closed off so
it's a better idea to try and see where
these ponds want to be and then go from
there so one way to consider could be be
three
I feel like Peter is like a kind of
stable move you have to take it because
if you don't white will take this pond
and that pond most likely will fall and
now White has another target see for the
idea is let's it take take not sure how
you would stop c-4 because whatever you
do see force coming up and I might not
even need to take but I can just keep
the dis pressure on and maybe try to go
from something like c5 and gain more
space there but I like the idea of b3
anyways in the game Alexandre play
tonight c2 and now queenie 8 was played
in the game see queenie 8 is pretty cool
because you want to bring the queen to
either like g6 or like h5 and you would
take this night and bring out the queen
depending on where with whites Queen go
but these are the moves that black
should be going for this Queen coming to
King's side so at this point white went
about it with f3 and after is also
another of those moves that is pretty
cool because like f3 + b3 were one of
the candidates because you wanna you're
asking
your opponent what do you want to do if
you keep it here I will take it and your
pawn structure will be kind of horrible
so the only way to sorry respond to it
is to go about it like something like
take my white can take back and now
black actually played Bishop d7 because
see if you take I can just take back
with the rook and this Bishop is really
strong here this Bishop is really not
doing much over there so that's probably
why black played Bishop d7 first
attacking this pawn and now if you take
on e4 black would take here and even if
you take here this is still okay because
now the bishops are little open and
jumping a little so it's better compared
to this after Bishop d7 in the game
white played 91 which i think is pretty
cool because if take then you could
always take with the night you don't
really have to take with the rope and
exchange that off also you're defending
your pawn over here so after 91 black
realized that this idea of Queen and
Bishop attacking the pawn isn't really
real anymore so let's relocate the Queen
what I spoke English - I'm assuming just
because reinforcements I don't really
think white is going for something like
g4 but it's always to create it's always
a good idea to create that's question
for your opponents like what if I play
g4 and at four and go out crazy
so black did take on f3 Knight takes
with F tree and now Bishop eh Bishop
here it's idea is pretty simple wants to
move the Queen away bring the bishop to
h5 or bring the bishop to g6 and fish up
to e4 or d3 and you just want to make
this bishop better in the game while
it's Queen e1 I'm assuming because of
something like Bishop d6 move g4 is kind
of looking pretty tempting right now
because if the Queen goes away least of
all I can just pull a [ __ ] over for but
even if that is too scary and if
anything it doesn't work and move like
Bishop g6 it feels a little premature
you could even try to play Queen eg tree
and kind of like block this idea because
if bishop moves then it's meat so in the
game black played Queen g6 and
what do you think whites should do it's
a super strategic and positional game so
one thing to think about is stop
stabilizing these pawns over here with a
move like a five it doesn't necessarily
have to happen now but it's something
that it's a good idea to do at some
point
any ideas
you don't like this bishop
okay
well one thing to think about is you
could try to move this special way to
wanna play 95 maybe and that's what they
did in the game White has some ideas to
try to play maybe 95 and maybe push for
a for some stuff like that
so black followed up is queenie for to
block those ideas now why it's quite a 5
which i think is actually a nice idea
because you are stable at stabilizing
the queenside and now you might want to
start doing stuff in the center like
maybe Queen d2 e 4 so in the game black
point h6 and I believe the idea was that
after Knight d2 black could play Queen
age 7 and now white gets to play E 4 E 4
is actually a very nice idea because
these are like doing nice targets to try
and attack see this is like shish kebob
if I could take it then this e 6 pawn is
pinned so whoops so but I kind of have
to take this because if well I couldn't
why it just takes the pawn and it's when
picking up a free pawn probably e6 2 so
after taking on e4 you don't necessarily
have to immediately take back with the
knight or queen just because you put
eforp on and choke you don't have to
take back especially because this pawn
is bad here as it is it's kind of like
blinding this Bishop this Bishop can't
really do anything can't come to c6 is
blind can go to g6 blind and why it's
good to go up after this c4 pawn now in
the game white try to go for a little
bit more than just taking back the pawn
with Bishop e5 black white rook c8 to
defend the c4 pawn rook skal exchange
and now Queen e2 why it's really going
for this pawn now the question is what
squad Campbell active
okay yeah maybe but I feel like the
question isn't if you can't keep these
pawns the question should be is it worth
it to try and keep the puns
so in the game joangel actually played
III to give this pawn up whoops but
might have been slightly better to think
about something like Bishop e7 because I
move like Bishop e7 you are kind of
developing this guy back into the game
and I might want to go Bishop g5 it's
like this Knight or simply want to
activate this Bishop more so in the game
after e3 now do you think you could play
Queen takes III or you could go after
the c-4 pawn maybe with Knight takes e4
but you have Petri
big palm 2p3 that's actually what's
happened in the game good I 964 Bishop
b5 p3 because if not Bishop b5 then the
knight can take this guy to whoops
so this should be 5 b3 and in the game
they played Queenie for Joe and Jim
played Queenie for it seems as if Queen
g6 would be slightly more mmm slightly
less better for white because after
Queenie for white actually has advantage
but after Queen g6 it's not as clear
because you can't really take this guy
because of exchange over here there as
when Queenie for you are directly
protecting this pawn but you are also
giving white ideas to bring you the
Rokan with something like rook f1 now
maybe it will comes to f4 maybe comes to
f3 you see it's giving white a lot of
good ideas
what do you want to do
what
the pawn is for safety
yeah but well actually that's what
happened the game after UK f1 what else
do you think black can do you do have
the right idea to keep more pressure
here but how can you do that
well something like Queen c6 is more
sufficient because Queen c6 you're
simply putting more pressure on this
night and you're moving away from the
rooks fire so Queen c6
now let's take this pun because if for
example take take take
I feel like this black left this side
really I'm like unprotected and it just
feels like something should be happening
here even if it's just bringing in more
pieces it just looks too good why it has
too much pressure on blacks whites could
probably simply play something like
Queen f3 and go for this square or maybe
just Queen a4 I mean cleanup street also
has some ideas but maybe the pawn so I
think this should be a pretty cool
advantage so in the game Jim and Jim
played Queen e8 I would assume that the
idea is to simply come back to g6 but
you can already see that white is quite
better here in the game
white continues with Queen comes to e2
and I feel like the idea is just see in
this position I wanted to I wanted this
pawn off as white and I kind of want
this Queen to go away and in this
position that's what I got that's why
it's so Queen came to g6 again and I
feel you see it was like a nice weird
circle and so now why it's bringing in
more reinforcements maybe you want to go
to g3 it's active clean and stuff
black played King gauge 7 to try and
keep the king more cozy
I would assume white continues it Queen
f2 attacking this guy maybe some Brook
have seven ideas or cheater anymore
so Bishop c6
now Bishop c6 is kind of a nice trick
because you can't take any more because
of this weakness and well mate but at
the same time it kind of pushes you to
go rook g3 you see
and now after rock g3 Queen can only
come to f5 because if you would click
Queen e8 again this is really weak like
some I mean at least 96 should be good
enough Bishop d6 rook takes g7 King
moves away Queen of four please tell me
this is winning yeah
probably more straightforward ooh
maybe this is also nice tactics yeah I
still see tactics and the King was
regardless Queen g7 is mate
so something like Queenie 896 is
actually very dangerous so Queen of five
is the only move to seriously consider
and even after that white gets to do 22
now Queen e2 idea is that I have a good
position I just want to keep my position
like this I also want to play like 96
again fork this broken this Queen and
also you can't really take it because of
this week pawn over here cool
so in the game for quadruped e8 but
rocked it is simply to avoid Knight d6
but I think probably a move like Queenie
for was slightly better because the
Queen is more active have some ideas now
you have to move the Queen as white
probably to d2 or something like that
and now you could do rooty eight to
protect so the idea is that simply you
are improving your Queen as black so
anyways rook c8 and if I'm not mistaken
this game's time control is like at for
tat move 40 you get extra time so most
likely if I had to guess they were both
in like super time trouble and they were
just trying to make some moves to get to
move 40 so I move like rook t8 could
possibly be due to that now white make
Knight e3 attack the Queen get the extra
time move 40
Queen has to move goes to the f7 still
we get extra time boom now in this
position actually it's kind of cool
because usually a lot of the mistakes
that happens or in occurrences that
happens is right after move 40 like your
detention is high adrenaline is jumping
your heart is beating like crazy you
just got the time and you can't like you
can't really control your emotions so
you make a mistake or you play
inaccurate so it's actually a very good
idea to usually after move 40 to get up
go to the just go wash your face walk
around a little take a sip of water
something to calm yourself down so you
can actually use your brain not just
being defense and defense in attack mode
so here and the game Aleksandra plays
Queen d3 which is a good move I would
even say that good enough to keep the
advantage but there is a better move can
you take a little bit of time and think
about it maybe you'll find it
that's also a nice idea you're bringing
in pure queen but this move is more
dynamic okay not too crazy it's more
dynamic you remember how it was a good
idea to play earlier
efore to just blind the bishop so I
think it's good idea to consider doing
something like that again just to blind
the bishop
what
what
you mean d5 yeah yeah d5 is pretty cool
move because after d5 you kind of have
to take check and if you move the King
there are all sorts of stuff that could
be happening rook g6 Knight f5 this h6
pawn should be winning enough but also
here so not King h8 so g6 now you're
opening up new weaknesses so Knight g4
you see like it's it's just it's not
about which move is like winning or not
it's more about which move makes your
opponent more miserable it's kind of
about that because this bishop is it
still kind of has some hopes but after
if in this position this bishop is kind
of hopeless and the king is more exposed
and again makes perfect sense not to go
for this line right after getting your
extra times because that could be a bad
move you're like you can't make that
judgment sometimes you are like hind you
have so much adrenaline you're like high
on this rush your heart is still going
crazy so
yeah so with Queen d3 g6 happens again
because King moving is still not an
option
least of all there's 94 mm Brooke g6
should be also good enough bunch of
stuff so g6 now how can you increase the
pressure as white
you have the right idea you want to
bring more stuff here but also a good
idea but not the best
a little too crazy no it's just about
bringing more pressure rubgy for ya now
you might want to go rootage for or look
f-for so I think the better idea is to
go something like Bishop e7 the game was
followed at Bishop g7 and now Africa for
Queen goes away I mean it's very
unpleasant White is also still upon up
and but you're still fighting but after
Bishop g7 take take Knight goes to c4
and this is such a weak square it's just
really hard for black to want to keep
any sort of attack going so here black
continued with Bishop b5 so blacks idea
is simple want to take this guy first of
all it's pinned so yeah so think about a
move that on pins that's nice
I think that's the first thing that you
should be calculating
at
just take back with the Queen
well you are you have more material so
it's not the worst idea to think about
exchanging but if you exchange the
Queen's off you wouldn't be using the TT
Kings weakness you have the right idea
the Queen should come this side so
whoops Queen goes to g3 now the idea is
that you want to go 95 nice and simple
so black has to take you take back now
if you got to the endgame
this is already an endgame of like Queen
and rook versus Queen and rook and it's
you are White has one more pawn and a
better attack towards the weak King so
this should be pretty nice and easy you
just as white you just have to do
accurate moves and don't lose your cool
basically so rooty seven now this is a
nice new shiny target so let's go for it
rookie four and the game they played
Queen of six but I would I think
something like rookie 7 might be a
little more accurate just because even
if check now it mmm it kind of feels off
and the way it happened in the game with
Queen f6 and Queen e3 it's White has a
better flow of the moves and now you
can't do 7 anymore because of d5 whereas
here if you did rookie 7 use d5 doesn't
work yet
stop Queen f6 Queen comes to e3 Brooke
had to go to d6 to protect that time now
simply c5 I'm attacking your rope you
can only go to c6 and here white I
actually played a very chill move
kang ji-hwan i think the way to think
about it is why it doesn't want to get
any checks anywhere and kingi one is the
way to go for it because you are taking
away most of the checks that could
happen in this diagonal or some ideas
with queen of fun maybe some time so
you're just taking it easy and bringing
your king in a safe place so black
continued with Queen a5 which is a bad
move you see here g5 could have been a
little bit more feisty because taking
away more squares gaining some space and
like shooting the ball in White's corner
and asking all right so what do you want
to do so after Queen a5 look at for
pretty clear idea Queen g5 now you get
to play h4 now where can the Queen go if
Queen goes to h5 already very scary
maybe something like g4 - too crazy
let's not go there
you could simply try and bring your
Queen here to go for up 7 or actually
Queen f2 could be very nice because you
might even want to go for g4 now so the
Queen also in the corner is not the
place that black wanted to be so after
Queen is 7 white can't get to give a
check the King has to go away now rook
f6 you see it how much pressure black is
under root f-ck
putting more pressure on g6 King age 7
now
it is winning for white so give me the
move it's not a crazy drug sacrifice or
stuff like that it's more about putting
pressure
exactly very good move the problem is if
g5 White House something like g4 and it
it's kind of like a zoo song because
what can black too and also next move
something like queenie for queen g6 is
coming up but i can't really move this
trip because this pawn files but i can't
really move the Queen cuz well first of
all where would you go
second of all something like group g6
coming up putting whoops putting more
pressure so it's sort of a Zuke's long
so take on each five now you bring your
Queen to f4 you simply want to put
Justin eat the Queen the best way to
also you're going for this the best way
for black to respond is with t5 because
if naruki of 7y black would just move
the king most likely seems a little
awkward honestly but the problem is if
you take also takes your clean back
there rock endgame still should be
pleasant for white but this is not the
position you want to get out of this and
so Queen h6 is the best and act most
accurate way to go King g8 Queen comes
to g6 check King estate all right
find me the win
yep
another check
please six doesn't work
I mean that the problem is like this was
the position and I mean you can click on
issues again but the King goes to g8 and
you had that position right here you
could repeat the once and just
yeah take this nothing wrong with eating
pawns you don't have to always find meat
now the king goes to g8 Queen g5 now the
thing is if the King goes to h8 there is
this rootage 6 that is that picks up the
Queen also if something like Queen g7
just go the simple way exchange all of
this off and your two pawns up in a pawn
and game it's good enough no need to be
super crazy just bring out your king and
win this endgame yeah I do believe that
after Queen g5 black resigned so it was
a very interesting game and coriaci and
I managed to force playoffs which are
happening few hours from now I I'm not
sure about the time difference but
within the next let's say 12 hours oh so
like 4 or 5 hours whoops 3 hours yeah in
3 hours they start playoffs and in the
morning when we all wake up we'll have
an world champion woman real champion
yeah that's actually pretty cool to talk
about games of the day instead of games
of the week and yeah this was a very
interesting game I yesterday I wanted to
do the game between Carlson and Pharaohs
job the day before that I was planning
on doing the game between Fabian on
Firoz ja so because well those are the
nice games but other people at the Chess
Club beat me to it and they did those on
other streams so that was pretty cool
but yeah I'm glad that today we have a
very decisive a result and with the test
well yeah it was pretty fun I hope you
enjoyed it and see you next time
[Music]
you